هنا في الكونجرس يدلي المدير التنفيذي
لتيك توك شيزوتشو بشهادته في حين ان
المدير التنفيذيه لشركه ابل تمكوك موجود
في بكين والقى خطابا امام منتدى التنميه
الصيني السنوي والمطالب من الطرفين
الثابته حمايه البيانات عملا بمبدا
المعامله بالمثل طلبت الصين تيم كوك
بتقويه ابل لاجراءات حمايه البيانات لكن
عكس التيك توك في امريكا فالصين هي شريك
رئيسي وسوق كبير للشركه ابل تقول ان
مبيعاتها في الربع الاخير من العام الماضي
قدرت باربعه وعشرين مليار دولار تقريبا في
الصين ما يجعل البلاد ثاني اكبر سوق
لمبيعات ابل خارج الولايات المتحده بعد
اوروبا
امر اخر مختلف فيما يخص التطبيقات
والاجهزه الالكترونيه في الصين والولايات
المتحده افضل التطبيقات الصينيه وجدت
جمهورا كبيرا في الولايات المتحده
150 مليون مستخدم النشط شهريا لتيك توك
مثلا لكن القليل من التطبيقات الامريكيه
قادره على اختراق السوق الصينيه حيث ان
معظم عمالقه البرمجيات في الولايات
المتحده غير قادرين على العمل في الصين
بسبب مطالب الرقابه لكن ابل تحاول تغيير
هذه الصوره حيث سجلت ارقام شحنها للهواتف
خلال الربع الثاني من العام الماضي
ارتفاعا قياسيا بتسعه ملايين وتسعمائه الف
جهاز بالمقارنه مع نفس الفتره من عام 2021